Well, I think my
opinion on grief
can be summed up in the
words of Alan Harrington
from The Immortalist when he
says, "any philosophy that
accepts death must itself be
considered dead-- its questions
meaningless, its
constellations worn out."
I agree with him.
I don't think there's
any way to make peace
with death, with mortality,
with the human condition.
The fact that we can
ponder the infinite cosmos,
yet we're ultimately
food for worms
I find heartwrenchingly,
paralyzing, depressing, sad
beyond all measurable limits.
The idea that everything
and everyone you love
is going to be taken away from
you is unacceptable to me.
I think it's just
unacceptable being
OK with those terms imposed
on us by said universe.
If the cosmos is comfortable
with entropy, that's one thing.
It doesn't mean I have to
be comfortable with entropy.
In fact, I'm a member
of the kingdom of life.
And life is anti-entropic.
Life moves towards greater
complexity and organization.
As Kurzweil says, more
knowledge, more science, more,
more, more sprouting
possibilities.
And some people say that maybe
death is an evolutionary design
meant to get rid of the old in
order to make room for the new.
That may have been a stepping
stone, a necessary rehearsal,
a way of spreading the
diversity of information.
Sex and death-- genes mixed
together creates something new,
kill off the old shells.
But what if we're able
to create new rules?
What if we master biotechnology?
We create software that
writes its own hardware.
We start to change
the rules of life.
We start creating
that diversity.
We start to be the sort
of mind at work here.
It would be intelligent
design at last.
But the point being, death
would no longer be necessary.
And we could create
a world without loss
and without those
encounters with grief.
And that may sound like a sort
of manic fantasy of sorts.
But I think that's
what mankind has always
done through his art,
is articulate his desire
to be external, to be infinite.
Even Miguel De Unamuno
wrote, "nothing
is real that is not eternal."
That's why we
write poetry and we
build cathedrals that try
to create transcendence
as a topographical statement.
That's why we eternalize
beautific moments,
and make gorgeous statues,
and write amazing songs.
We love to eternalize ourselves.
We want to say, as
Alain de Botton said,
we want to carve our names.
We want to say, I was here.
I exist.
I felt something and I matter.
And we matter.
And that's why death has become
an imposition on the human race
and no longer
acceptable, in my words.